nicholas how you doing
hey rich what are you doing
good so you're
so sorry what's your problem you're
getting flaked on
yeah
okay
so
so like my question is i'm uh you know
like i'm 20 years old right now and i
hit the gym i'm on my purpose i got the
game i got to look but i'm working on my
purpose right now and trying to make
bank and
have a high status you know like
and i'm read the [ __ ] i mean i've been
consuming your content and other content
creators for the past three years and
oh my god i'm really excited right now
like i've been watching your content for
the past few years and you know like it
feels really amazing right now so
my question is i mean whatever you know
like no matter what i do i mean you're
like i'm not successful like because
you know like woman flake on me even
though
i did the right thing and it doesn't
make any sense at all i mean i
approached what
what percentage of of dates that you set
up do they end up flaking on you uh
probably like 70 percent
70
yeah 60 to 70 percent
and
and how old are these women you said
you're 22
no i'm 20 years old and they're like 25
years old 24 years old i mean sometimes
so you're 20 and they're older than you
yeah
yeah well 25 year old women generally
don't have a lot of interest in a 20
year old guy yeah sometimes you know
like 18 i mean i don't know i just
approach women in real life i don't
really use dating apps and you know like
well look i mean if you're if you're
trying to set up dates with women like
you're you're 20 and she's 25 the 25
year old chick
probably doesn't live at home wants to
go out and do cool [ __ ] and be
entertained
and if an older guy with a cool car or
a beach house or a boat or something
says yo let's you know what are you
doing this weekend her phone's blowing
up already there's like her phone is
basically a box of dicks like guys are
hitting her up constantly hey what are
you doing let's get together let's grab
a drink
and if you think she's going to carve
out time for a guy that's five years
younger than her like do you have a lot
of money do you have a nice car do you
have a beach house you have a boat
yeah i don't but actually you know like
the thing is right so 25 year old girls
are hanging out with guys that have that
kind of stuff right so i mean yeah
you're going to get flaked on so one of
your problems is you're is you're
expecting a high close rate on a
demographic that doesn't typically
respond well to you
so like what can be the solution i mean
i think
that are 19 20 21.
yeah but you know like my question is
you know like i talked to women who are
18 19 i mean and i have really high
sexual market value because you know
like you can't see my physique right now
but i've been in the gym for the past
like eight years and
you know like i got the game but you
know like something doesn't work i mean
you know like i'm just trying to find a
solution to
the problem itself are you just playing
like you know dude game on them like
look at me i'm a rip jack dude and you
know you just go out with me because of
that
no actually you know like i just
approached him and you know like i
didn't go outside to approach mood but
whenever i see you know like an
attractive girl i just you know like i'm
like hey okay okay let me ask you this
question when you're setting up dates
with 20 year olds as they flake on you
at the 60 to 70 percent rate
uh yeah they're like you know uh i got
something to do and i'm like i break the
flake i leave them on scene i don't
insist on you know what are you what do
you offer to do with them like what sort
of dates are you offering to take them
out on actually on the first date i mean
you know like i didn't you know like i
go you know like i'm like let's drink
something you know like because i don't
want to pay a lot of money on the first
date like eating something or stuff like
that because
you know like uh some woman you know
like can exploit men for eating food for
free and you know like and i'm like
let's sing out you know like let's grab
a drink we can you know like have fun
and cheer you know okay so the first
date is a drink so what do you do for
the second date
uh
you know like actually i tried to
increase the sexual tension by taking
action instead of talking you know like
and i try to you know like
do something fun because you know like
women want to have fun and you know like
i try to be
captivating as much as possible and you
know like i you know like i don't i
don't really go into deep topics i just
keep it fun amusing and this is what i'm
trying to do and you know do you
do your work do you have your own place
uh actually you know like probably two
months you know yeah within few months
i'm gonna go to europe i'm not living in
europe right now so
uh
i'm i'm working with my dad right now
and i'm living with my dad right now but
i think about going to germany you know
like within two months and where do
you live in turkey and and you're
thinking about just doing some traveling
throughout europe or
no actually i'm gonna go to college as a
student oh you're gonna go to college
okay so i mean like you're calling
yourself a high value guy but i mean
you've got looks but that's it right you
don't even have a plan and you don't
even have your own place and
you know i mean like hey you know like
let's go for that date and if she digs
your vibe i mean you know she's gonna
dig your vibe like you can't like
genuine burning desire is obvious as
hell right you've read my book
yeah i did yeah so
look i mean you're doing a few things
wrong here right i mean
one of the other things you're doing
wrong too is you're chasing tail like
crazy like
all that you're
about right now is like why is my flake
rate so high i want to get more girl
sort of thing right
at 20 years old dude like what do we
just finish talking about right chase
excellence not women yeah actually i do
uh right now i'm working on programming
and i think about building on my own
business and uh i'm writing a book about
uh something i'm interested in and you
know like i put in the work i hit the
gym and i work on uh building up my
business right
again
again your results aren't where you want
them to be you can always tell what
somebody's belief system and choices are
like by looking at their results and i'm
looking at your results and you're
saying 60 to 70 of women flake on me
when i set a date so that tells me that
your beliefs around dating and around
unplugging and repel awareness a lot of
stuff aren't where they should be
if you want a much better close rate and
you want to deal with fewer flakes right
like
women will flake like let's be honest
they will
but 70 is way too much and again you
know we talked about you're dating or
you're trying to set up dates with women
that are
like too far out of your range you
should be dating 19 20 year olds 18 19
20 21 that's it
yeah i tried to play the numbers game
because you know like i know that
luminar flaky and you know like
increasing my options
yeah so why even bother if you know that
it's not going to work out well right i
mean look
if you see a picture of a chick on a
dating app and it's one picture like
this with an aerial shot you know she's
fat right
yeah right
so like why even bother talking to her
like that's what i'm saying right like
why even
making the effort to try to close a
chick that's five years older than you
it's probably more interesting in dating
a guy with
something going on you know
yeah i got it actually you know like my
my purpose is not you know like hanging
out with women my i'm chasing actions
it's just that you know like i'm just
it's not the main thing i mean it's just
a question i mean you know like because
i'm i'm i'm three thousand dollars an
hour when people book me privately right
and what you're spending this time on is
why do girls flake on me so that's where
your priorities at
right so
my advice has been dispensed i would i
would encourage you to you know take the
little bar back and watch that last five
minutes over and over again until it
sinks in but
it is what it is my friend you know
you've gotta you know you've gotta come
to accept these things
yeah okay all right thanks man hey guys
i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you